قرارات جديده ضد الصحفيين في مصر وحرياتهم
وفق جريده الوقائع المصريه اعادت محكمه
جنايات القاهره ادراج عشرات المصريين في
قائمه للارهاب لخمس سنوات اخرى بعد انتهاء
مده سابقه لادراجهم التعسفي من هؤلاء
صحفيون بشبكه الجزيره واعلامينا مصريون
يتجدد وضعهم على قوائم ارهاب سيئه السمعه
لسنوات طويله ينظم القانون رقم ثمانيه
لعام 2015 مساله قوائم الكيانات الارهابيه
والارهابيين وفق نص القانون فما الذي
يعنيه ادراج شخص على قوائم الارهاب في مصر
وفق الماده السابعه من القانون وبشان
الافراد يترتب على نشر قرار الادراج وطوال
مدته اثار تحول حياه صاحبها لمعضله من
جميع الجهات فهو يدرج على قوائم منع السفر
وترقب الوصول كما يسحب جواز سفره او يلغى
او يمنع من اصدار جواز جديد كما يفقد حسن
السمعه والسيره لتولي الوظائف العامه او
النيابيه وتجمد امواله متى استخدمت في
ممارسه نشاطه الارهابي وفق وصف القانون
وتلك معوقات كبلت حياه الاف المصريين منذ
عام 2013 فان ادرج اسمك وكنت داخل مصر لا
تحتاج افتراضا لجواز سفر فسيخنق رزقك
وفرصك في العمل لحرمانك من شهاده حسن
السيره فضلا عن تجميد اموالك اما المدرجون
خارج الوطن فخلال عشر سنوات انتهت صلاحيات
الاف وثائق السفر ولم يسمح لاصحابها
بتجديدها وولد لعدد منهم اطفال لم
يستطيعوا تسجيلهم فضلا عن الحاقهم بمدارس
لاحقا منذ صدر قانون الكيانات الارهابيه
رقم ثمانيه لعام 2015 وحتى نهايه مارس
الماضي رصدت منظمات حقوقيه ادراج خمسه
الاف وثلاثمائه واربعه عشر شخصا على قوائم
الارهاب التي تجد كل خمس سنوات بشكل تعسفي
ودون محاكمه او سند قانوني واضح وفضلا عن
ادراج الصحفيين على قوائم الارهاب ما زال
خلف الاسوار الزميلان ربيع الشيخ وبهاء
ابراهيم لكن يبقى ان اليه الادراج على
قوائم الارهاب تحديدا باتت وفق حقوقينا
تبتزل جديه محاربه الارهاب في مصر تبقى
تساؤلات كثيره بشان قوائم الارهاب في مصر
وادراج الصحفيين والسياسيين عليها خاصه في
ظل ما يروج له الاعلام الموالي للسلطه حول
سقوف حريه اخذه في الارتفاع واجواء حوار
وطني وتعدديه تحظى بترويج حافل